following on from Paul's talk about some
of the ways to think about becoming or
what it takes to become or whether you
might believe you might become a hundred
billion dollar business I am going to
have a conversation with Mathilde : who
is in the process of building one of
those hundred billion dollar businesses
and she's going to be able to tell us
all about that and her company called
front so Mathilde what patch were you in
at YC summer 14 summer 14 Wow already
four years ago so tell us about your if
you would your journey to being the CEO
of front sure so in just a few seconds
so I think I've always been wanting to
start a company but the main thing is I
didn't feel confident enough do you
think that I would when they build a
company so I was hearing all these
people saying oh yeah I'll start a
company and I was like I wish I could
say that potatoes don't feel like I can
do it so instead what I did is after I
graduated I joined a startup that was
super small doing a contract management
software and that's when I discovered
the world of software's and there is
something that went well during this
first experience and something that
didn't do well so what went well is I
became very passionate about software in
general and I just felt like the fact
that you could build something in a few
months that could change how people work
and people spend so much time at work I
felt was super rewarding so that's what
went well so so the you didn't find its
contract management sounds painfully
boring
yes it's boring but what was cool about
it was that it actually changed how
right so did they're exactly and so when
I was talking to people also I was in
charge of launching a new product for
them and so when I was talking to people
using the product and they were telling
me how their day-to-day was much better
because they were using the product it
made sense to me and it's still one
thing that drives me today so that's
what that's what was great what wasn't
great is the culture was terrible and so
I was very unhappy and I also understood
how much of a responsibility
you had as you know a funding team of a
company to create an environment where
people would be happy to to come to work
so a year after I joined this company I
quit this company and you can you
elaborate a little bit what what what
was it about the culture that that was
bad so I think the main thing is there
was no transparency and so then there is
no trust and then there is no engagement
from employees so I can tell you more
about how I've built the front and I
think what's unique about our culture
but one of the things is how transparent
we are and I don't believe that
transparency is good in itself and
that's why you should be transparent I
believe that that's the most efficient
way I've found to create engagement at
scale so if you ask people at France why
are you happy to come to work every day
they will tell you I'm happy because I
can see the impact of my work and that's
what I care about and how do you make
sure that people see the impact of their
work you make sure that everything is
transparent from where you want to go
how you'll go there what are the goals
that need to achieve and how their work
relate to these goals it seems like
there's something really fundamental
there for the companies that are going
to be successful Paul talked about what
it felt like at Google where everyone
knew where they were going and everyone
was passionate everyone believed and so
you had this energy in the company so I
guess somehow it this is about sharing a
vision with the team and having them
believe in it and at every step in the
way having them be able to see how that
vision is being created yeah so I think
there are two things that are incredibly
important as early as you are so one is
the vision and of course you should know
where you're going and of course you
don't know yet and that's totally fine
like I didn't know four years ago how a
big front would be and I still don't
know today but I think that will just
evolve along the way what you need to
have is just what you deeply believe in
and so what I've always believed in is
friend should be a place where people
come to work every day and are happy and
our customers should be happier because
they use front either because you know
the impact of their work is higher or
because it's an email products that is
ten hours in the app every day but
that's what drove me and so today our
mission is work happier and I make sure
that I explain
people what it means for us and I think
it should be clear to everyone in your
company and you why you care so deeply
about about what you're doing and it
doesn't mean he doesn't need to be you
know this huge idea because the truth is
I didn't know what front would be but I
knew that I cared so much about it and
people could relate to it so that's one
thing super important yet I don't think
that that's the most important thing I
think the most important thing is
discipline and I think that discipline
is actually more important than having a
grand vision and my personal belief and
I am sure that not a lot of people agree
with me is one of the reason why we've
been successful so far is because we've
been incredibly disciplined in many many
things so for example always have in one
focus and making sure that it's clear to
the entire company so in the early days
we wanted to make sure that we were
making something that people wanted and
the way we would track that was can we
generate revenue and so every single day
everyone in the company would know where
our revenue was and the next day where
it was in the next day it's a track for
at least a year and anything that we
would work on was aimed at increasing
that revenue and I was sending daily
emails that became weekly emails there
are still weekly emails telling everyone
how we're doing against our core targets
and I think having this discipline of
focusing on a few things and making sure
that in every presentation you're doing
every email you send even to investors
to whatever you show that will be one of
the key to succeed so let's back up
before we dig further into the sort of
the unique culture and the success
you've had at front
you left the the the lousy startup the
lousy company with a lousy culture and
somehow you ended up deciding you're
going to start your own thing how did
how did that transpire what what what
led you to start your company to find
your co-founder Aloha and and get going
with front yeah so I think it was very
lucky for a few reasons
so
one is I met my co-founder so the story
of my co-founder and I is not that you
know we were best friends or brothers
and sisters or whatever I actually met
my co-founder three months before we
started the company and then we spend so
much time together trying to go through
every hard conversations that I could
think about like I don't know what if I
want to fire you what if you want to
fire me what if you want to sell and I
don't want to sound bah bah bah and we
were just aligned on most things
actually everything so that's one thing
that led me to start this company with
him then we found angel you knew you
wanted to start a company yes so I knew
I wanted to start a company I quit the
software company I knew I wanted to
start a company in the email space
because I love software's but I was
using email to get work done I wasn't
yeah I wasn't using contracts and so I
knew that and I knew that I needed money
to start a company because I had to have
a loan for my school and so I couldn't
start a company if I didn't find money
yet so I was lucky enough to meet with
an angel investor in Paris who committed
to giving us when you sue franchise that
sounds really risky though you had
college debt right you just left your
job yeah and I don't know if that's the
biggest risk I took or when I moved here
with all the our employees and their
family and they quit their jobs and sold
their house I've taken many a risk in my
life right Wow
so so you decided to jump in headlong
you had to get money you got an angel
investor you found long yes and the last
thing that I think is incredibly
important is I found someone that became
my husband later on who believed in me
and I think that it's so important to
find someone whether it's you know a
mentors friend or whoever who can tell
you that you can do it and maybe you
already know that you can do it but at
least for me like these four things were
equally important I would have never
started this company if someone was not
telling me every day you can do it so
you found your future husband and your
co-founder different people by the way
at about the same time my husband works
at front although your husband this work
but you you met them at the city he
didn't work at front at the time and you
met them about the same time I met my
future husband a few years before but he
was the one telling me you can do it so
he was supportive of you quitting your
job and jumping in headlong into the
startup yes and he did the same thing at
the same time right so and how did you
meet uh-huh
so in Paris we met in a startup studio
called the founders we and it was it was
love at first sight
how how did the two of you decide who
was going to be CEO that it was very
easy so basically everything I love you
hates and everything he loves I hate so
he's the CTO of front
he loves building the product but it
isn't like talking what I am doing right
now it isn't like managing as much and I
think that when I reflect back on the
front the thing that I've been most
lucky with is my relationship with my
co-founder because we have the most
amazing relationship and what I mean by
that is not that we're super close in a
sense that we would hang out together
and bow like is actually he's a friend
but he is not like my best friend or my
buddy but we have so much respect for
one another and that's the thing that
you need to optimize for it doesn't
matter how well you get along you just
need to be so impressed by whatever your
other person or other persons are doing
and you you had sort of a unique process
to figure that out in the beginning you
you sort of grilled each other until you
were both sure that you were comparing
yeah so when you began as CEO what can
you talk a little bit about how you
split up responsibilities and what the
role of CEO was there's a lot of people
here who have similar questions as to
what exactly they should be doing is CEO
how did you think about that from the
beginning so a few things so my role as
a CEO in the early days I was basically
doing everything but
being an engineer because I wasn't an
engineer's but so I was the product
manager the recruiter I was for the
longest time the onion marketing person
for three years I was the only sales rep
I was the onion support rep I was the
only customer success person and I guess
my job was just to do the job of like
what ultimately will become our team and
that was really what my goal was
everything but building yeah that was
you exactly how has that changed over
time we talked a bit with a lot Gil
about how the role of CEO evolved as a
company gets much larger but it changes
a lot even as you go from two people to
five people to ten people right sure so
I think what super important is I wasn't
expecting to hire people to figure out
things that I would have not figured out
so it wasn't like I'm struggling with
marketing like I don't know how to
generate leads so I need to hire someone
better than me so the way I was thinking
about it is there are a few things that
I feel are scalable so for example who
would have leads that would sign up to
France I would call them and I would
like do you understand at the front here
is what from des what's your process and
when when I started to think that
another person could do that and could
it better than me because the person
would be more skilled then that's when I
hired people and so at every step of the
way I hired people better than me but
once I had figured out what roughly
their job would be in the mistake I've
done in the early days was I've not
figured out something and I hope is that
someone will figure it out for me the
truth is if with all the knowledge I
have about the company I can't figure
out something I think it's very rare
that someone would come and figure it
out so that's something that I learned
in the early days so you can't count on
someone else to have the answers right
you don't have them yeah for sure and
Steve today like even today we are 110
people now and I'm not hiring people to
figure out things that I've not figured
out because I think it's incredibly hard
I'm here to hire people that will scale
what's kind of working so that's what
happened so I hired people that were
better than me on seeing that I had
figured out and then once I had everyone
I hired head of functions
and then my job now is to find the head
of every function and to make them work
together so that's how my job is
revolved so it sounds like from the very
beginning though hiring was was foremost
in your mind yes she rolled for this you
know so one funny thing is any time so I
was in the summer 14 batch and so every
week we had a speaker and every time the
speaker was talking about hiring that's
the moment I was in my phone because I
was like you know I don't care hiring is
a long time from now on and that's
probably a big mistake I've done because
then you understand that hiring is the
key if you fell on that your company
will fail so you should listen and just
take notes and read the notes later on
so this I can tell you one piece of
advice that I got from Patrick Allison
the CEO of stripe that I thought it was
super insightful they said in the early
days every time you hire someone just
think about whether you want 10 times
this person because the truth is this
person will hire people like them so I'm
interviewing you and I'm like do I want
10 Jeff in this team yeah so if the
answer is you know maybe I do so if the
answer is yes then you know I can hire
you if the answer is no but the bar
should be as high as that and I think
that was a good piece of advice that I
received from the very beginning it
seems like front has a strong specific
culture yes did you pay attention to
that as you were hiring from the
beginning and and how did you how did
you implement that how did you think
about it yes I think very early on I was
very deliberate about it was what we
call today our values but I basically
know who I think I would work well with
and who I wouldn't work well with and
that's the truth like our values or just
extensions of who we are Aska founders
and so you know some of our values are
low ego and high standards care and
collaborate collaboration and the last
one is transparency and I just believe
that I'm incredibly demanding and that's
why high standards is part of our value
and I don't want to hire anyone that
doesn't have these standards I'm also I
think very low ego like it doesn't mean
I don't have
nigo but when I make a decision I think
about front first and I think about our
employees first and I think about myself
after and I think that just putting
words on what we care about as
co-founders and then making sure that
you're of your assessing that during
your interview process is what matters
it doesn't it's not useful to display
them on a wall and to explain them and
all of that in the early days but at
least being just self aware is what will
help you hire the right people and it
does kind of speak to the fact that you
are going to play an important role in
hiring everybody in the beginning yeah
and I kept interviewing everyone till
like employee number 80 or something did
you ever find yourself in a position of
needing or wanting or having to
compromise on those values or did the
values always take precedent like
there's there is someone who maybe
didn't quite match the values but was
like the perfect fit for the designer
job so no we'd never sew or if we did
then we let go the person after which is
where it's worse yeah never worked and I
think it's incredibly important in a
company that it's festering like you
think for example I've been willing to
hire a head of finance for I don't know
six months and it's so important like we
don't have any finance person at front
and we I don't know we're 110 people
we've raised 80 million and I'm I don't
know what I'm doing because I've never
done any finance work before but I've
never found someone that I was
incredibly excited about that had both
the skills and would match our values so
I'm not hiring anyone and I think being
very disciplined about not hiring even
if you desperately need this person is
important I want to move on to product
but before we do that I'm just wondering
if if you were going to talk to
relatively new startup founders or
people with young companies like most of
the companies in start-up school is
there specific advice you'd give about
creating a culture of success the
creating the kind of culture you have it
front for them so I think my biggest
advice would be one to be incredibly
demanding so I just feel like in the
early days if you have someone that's
not working out
being very tough and letting this person
go I think that's a mistake I've seen
because you know if you have a team of
five and one person is not working out
and you kind of know and you always know
and you're not making this tough
decision that it has an impact on your
entire team it's easy to say hard to do
and I can tell you how we've done it I
think that's super important I think
transparency is just so important in the
early days and even if even at scale but
so making sure that everyone in your
company knows everything like there is
no reason why you should hide anything
maybe except for I don't know salaries
so I was going to ask well when you say
transparency people throw that word out
a lot how do you what what in in actual
practice what does that mean for you at
front so it means that everyone knows
what icon so few things when I think
there is bad transparency and good
transparency real transparency is
everything that you can share that will
help people do their job better and help
answer question they have that
transparency will raise more questions
and create more problems than you need
and so for example like sharing salaries
like we can have a debate about that but
I think it raises more questions than in
the actually solve and solve problems
but then everything else so everyone
knows or revenue or churn every email
about I don't know leads coming in and
telling us what they want customer
complaining about this or being happy
about that every NPS score that is here
either people are super happy super
upset everything is public or run away
the amount of cash we have in the bank
account every board meeting that we do
we publish the board egg then I do in Oh
hands and I share what the board said in
or I answer questions on the board egg
every I don't know I share just
everything that's business-related
and also how I feel like I'm happy to
say I'm extremely happy about that and
I'm extremely and have you about that
and ever and every one of the company
ends up knowing that and they know that
and I think it's good because then if
you really want people to work on this
thing that are broken there is no point
in hiding what's broken and there is
always this this human feeling of I will
not share because you know they will be
worried I'm gonna tell them that that's
broken and some people join two days ago
and they're gonna know that it's broken
but that's fine because what you gain is
the fact that they will all work on the
program and that's better than avoiding
the question and it feels like people
stay aligned and moving in the same
direction yes and I mean you know that
but I think frontiers like at least one
thing there are lots of things that you
know we struggle with but one thing that
we've done I think very well is our
retention of employees so people are
super happy our NPS is 87th which is
super high if you look at Glassdoor
we only have five stars reviews if you
look at our attrition
no one has there are just two people
that have left front ever and it was one
to go back to school one to join the
company of their best friend so I think
we've done a good job and I believe that
we've done a good job because of this
engagement that we've created thanks to
this transparency we were talking
earlier about one great sign for company
their company's product is having really
high retention but likewise I guess
having really high retention of your
employees is a pretty fantastic sign for
our company
yeah and it's important because so much
knowledge is gather institutional right
and you every time you especially if you
lose someone good you lose so much money
so much so you guys are a really
interesting case because you're an
enterprise company that started with a
handful of customers well zero
eventually a handful and then you've
scaled to thousands can you talk about
the early days of figuring out that you
had product market fit and then and then
a little bit about the the evolution to
you know going from you know we were
just talking about ten or hundred people
who love you too
too many more yeah so I would say a few
a few things so first thing is I
remember when I arrived here in YC four
years ago Kevin Hale was came to me and
was like what's our company and says
like it's France and then it was like oh
so cool I think it's one of the coolest
company from this batch and
then I was sure that he was talking
about another company so as any true
like I just was sitting he was confused
about oh you must be you must be
confusing me with another couple it's
just like I wasn't confident in another
example is my batch mates would come to
me and say should we use your product
and I was like use our computer it's
much better it's true like I just I've
always been very ashamed with the
current state of the product and so and
so of course convinced that we didn't
have product market phase isn't that one
of the one of the definitions of product
market fit is a product that your
customers love but that you're ashamed
of I maybe I think it's actually a good
thing that you're ashamed of your
product but so product market fit at
least I can tell you that if you feel
like you don't have product market fit
right it doesn't mean that you're doomed
but then I think that there is a lot of
thing that we I'm also someone that's
like incredibly honest with myself and I
can't just wake up and think that I
don't have product market fit I need to
fix every single prime that I have so
how did I do that one is I've been
incredibly disciplined about talking to
as many users as possible
so my day to day @yc four years ago and
I can tell you what my day to day is
today but it's not very different
I was talking to leads and customers all
the time and I made sure that every
single day I had at least I don't know
seven eight meetings with people that
sign up to our product even if they
ended up not using our product doesn't
matter I want to talk to them and I want
to understand why they got initially
interested can I just stop you there
do you remember that this might be a
stretch but do you remember any specific
conversations that maybe change the
trajectory or at least change the
product so in significant ways yeah and
I actually in YC sue we started with
this email that was helping companies
menu cheering boxes so share the email
addresses like support add sales at and
that's what it was doing and then we
took to adora this year of homejoy and
we partner no voice upon her now YC
startup school awesome and so she told
me uh so the
that you've built it's awesome could it
work with SMS because they were chatting
through SMS with other cleaners and then
we looked at 12 yo and their EPA was
pretty good and so we realized that in a
week we could just add SMS as a new
channel and any droves so much revenue
because I think there was a big need for
collaboration around and I would have
never thought about it I've never worked
in a company that uses SMS to work but
and so that's one example but I have
many more I basically have never like
I've worked when you're in a company so
what do I know about business workflows
and still today the reason why I still
spend a ton of time talking to either
leads or customers is because we're
going up market we're going in new kinds
of companies and new use kisses and one
of the use keys that front is super
popular in is logistics and
transportation and so I'm going to these
tracking conferences and trying to
understand what do I know about their
awful is nothing you stand out at a
trucking comforts right I do
so if I don't talk to them then I can't
lead the company in the right way
because I can't hire the right people
make the right product decisions and so
I just believe that that's what I used
to do that's what I still do I think
it's insanely important and the only way
you'll manage to do that is by hustling
like the truth is when you're early and
you need to have eight meetings a day
it's insanely difficult and so you need
to do everything you can from reaching
out to all the people you know to
finding new ways to writing contents in
the hope of someone reading and then
ultimately signing up to your product
and that's what I did and I think that's
what's made us grow quickly in the in
the early days so when you entered YC do
you remember how many customers you had
so one thing I remember is when I am
when I interviewed at YC we had 3,000
companies that had sign up to our
product but it was closed beta so they
were not using it yet and then I was
unborn them one by one and every time
was the same thing great but we don't
want to use your product because you
don't have XYZ or it isn't it doesn't
work so maybe out of the 3,000 companies
maybe one ended up using the frogs but
that's just how I built so much
knowledge about what they wanted and
then I was telling no need to build that
or a one feature away I promise just one
features who an a future away I still
say that today and when you left why see
how many customers did you have so when
we left we see we had 5,000 mr and so we
had probably like 130 companies using
the product which is pretty amazing so
do you recall what the retention was of
those 130 companies yes so we hadn't had
a single user churn so basically the
reason why I'm saying that is cuz every
time someone drained the company at
front I show the video of demo day so I
know my dividend heart because I've
listened to it so many times and so part
of the pitch is we've haven't had a
single user churn so and that's good
right great it doesn't mean though so
that's great but what wasn't great is
our conversion rate from you know trial
to paid was terrible why was that I mean
just because the product was very early
and so didn't have a lot of the features
that the market needed so have you
managed to shift that over time yeah I
mean we've built more and more and so
our conversion has increased I want to
talk about how you went from hundreds to
thousands of customers but a question
that's come up a lot during start-up
school is like how do you figure out how
to price your product you talk about the
you know fronts pricing journey from
wherever you started to how you started
in to where you are now yeah so we
started with a freemium model so we had
3 or $9 per user per month one thing I
would say is just release your pricing
as early as possible because there is so
first you are always scared that you're
not ready but you're ready all of you at
least the good thing is that will
confront you to the market and that's
what you need to is when you want to
listen to some feedback you should
listen to feedback of people that are
paying some money because otherwise you
can be over one with feedback from
people that will never pay for your
product so we had a freemium model what
we realized is even if we had a free
product I think at the end we maybe had
15% of our users and the free plan so it
was more a distraction like it's good to
have a
Glenn if that's a way for you to get
AIDS and then you convert these leads
but if it's just something where you end
up having you know 15% of your users
it's not useful so removed it change it
into nine and nineteen consistently
increase prices over time maybe too much
do you feel like you started too low
yeah and I think 99.99% of people will
tell you that they started too so yeah
right it doesn't matter though because
you can increase price later it's harder
to increase than to decrease I suppose
yeah true but everyone does it how did
you come up with those numbers was it
this oh yeah it's I mean you can work is
so we're now for the first thing you ask
customers what they would pay and no no
I don't think they can I don't think
they can tell you they yeah I just do I
mean of course you can look at your kind
of competition and then make sure that
you're not ten times cheaper or ten
times more expensive but then once you
know that and you have a range of
speaker number and it is like in the
scope of distraction that you can have
in the early days like thinking too much
about the pricing is one of them just
pick a price and sell the products and
you'll see what people say I wanted to
dig more into one other thing about sort
of the initial stages of growth and
talking to customers is there any advice
you would give because you know you just
gave a really useful piece of advice
which is to talk to people who are
paying more than people who aren't but
what what advice can you give to people
who are trying to extract useful
feedback from customers yes so I mean I
think first of all you should understand
that not everyone wants to share
feedback in the same way and so for us
we had different ways to get feedback so
one of them was talking to people and so
people that would accept to talk to me I
would talk to them and they would tell
me I like this I don't like that but
another thing that we did was we were
using Trello for product roadmap and so
we published our Trello roadmap and so
if you even today if you go in front of
that comes a shred map you can see our
roadmap in public its public it's always
been public
I can talk about that but you can vote
for the thing that you want and that's
one of the way we got a ton of feedback
as well so I just felt like some people
and then another thing that we did was
every quarter at the beginning of the
quarter I would email all our customers
and I would say working on the roadmap
for this quarter what do you want to see
and then they would reply and so I think
it was a good mix of people that want to
spend a lot of time people that want to
spend some time and what I just want to
do one click but in anyway you need to
have this data so that sounds like it's
a little bit later in your evolution
when you're at Trello and you had a had
a roadmap and the very beginning when
you're trying to figure out you know you
talk to a door and figure out SMS what
was what was was that like how did you
know if you were talking to a customer
who was giving you useful feedback or
basically wasting your time yeah so I
mean so I think once you talk to someone
you have to figure out if you understand
the person really well because they can
tell you I think I want that and then
you build it and that's not what they
want so the best way you can think about
sales so I would bet that most of you
are not excited about doing a sales call
I mean that's my guess and it's normal
because I otherwise you would be doing
sales in a company and that was how I
felt
yeah that's how I felt as well so one
thing that I would say is the way I
thought about sales in the early days
was I wanted to make sure I understood
exactly where the workflows of people
where what their issue was and then
think afterwards confront solve it and I
think that then it becomes pretty
interesting so today when I do a sales
goal or sales meeting or customer
success meeting like I'm not here to
sell extra feature or to demo the
product like I find that a bit boring
but what I'm here to do is understand
exactly what their pin point is and what
the workflow is and then can I explain
to them how that could be better with
front if it can be better with front and
so I guess they're choosing that you
need to focus on when he is being
incredibly honest with yourself about
whether front is a good solution for
them and even today one of the things
that I struggle the most with is telling
our team
these are some news kisses we want and
these are some use cases we don't want
and being very deliberate about saying
yes and no in the early days is insanely
important and you know that the truth is
you know where you want this company to
be and you don't know how to dissent but
at least you can tell if that's
something you want or there's something
you do you want and then making sure
that you were super curious when you
were doing these sales calls and making
sure that it was more about
understanding something that someone is
telling you more than deeming the
product or showing a list of features
they probably don't care that much about
yeah so I want to come back to that
because it seems to hearken back to your
idea of discipline basically you're
saying you have to see notice some
customers because because if you want to
keep your turn down to zero and you sell
the wrong person the wrong product
you're going to have turn right and I
think the journey is not the the I think
the biggest danger I think the biggest
danger is you have a customer and then
you know you care so much about growing
your revenues so then they're telling
you I want this and so then you build
this and I want that and you build that
and then you just pull your you push
your product in a direction that you
don't want to go and I think that's the
biggest mistake let's talk a little bit
about sales because you have a I mean
you've had to learn about enterprise
sales all on your own
and you've had to build a sales force
talk a little bit about what that's been
like and what advice you would give to
people who are probably just a couple of
folks trying to figure out how to get
their product into customers hands so I
guess my advice based on a mistake I did
was first you need to figure out there
are different sales machines you can
have so for example you can have a
bottom-up approach or a top-down
approach so top-down you sell - I don't
know CIO and then they replay the
product but IMAP is you demo the product
to the end-user and because they tell
you that it could be a great tool then
that's how they'll buy and I think that
it's we try to do both and we've
struggled a lot and first of all I think
you should know how you want to sell
your product because the people you are
hire the way you will sell your like
everything will be different
if you're bottom-up or top-down so piece
of advice
now I can tell you that we started
bottom up so we had a lot of customers
and it was like it was a numbers game so
the only thing that I cared about was
our reps should call every lead five
times and should end up having 15 demos
every week and I don't care about how
they make it happen but I want to see
that level of activity and so you know
every morning we would receive an email
saying here are all the calls that have
been done and here are all the meetings
that have been scheduled and that have
been done and I think that the input is
far more important at this stage then
the output because the Tracie is if they
don't hit their target first your target
could be wrong and how could you know
what your target should be when you are
so early and - maybe your product is an
issue or maybe whatever your pricing is
an issue you don't know that so I've
always felt like if you look at the end
number it's actually pretty challenging
and you might blame someone for not
doing a good job or as they're doing a
really good job whereas if you look at
just number of demos and course they
make and if you check that they're not
saying stupid things then they're
probably doing a good job and you should
be happy and not for that you said
something to me the other day about
about what are the key lessons you
learned and you were kind of referring
to it earlier about about the importance
of listening versus describing your
product yeah so I think the tendency
like you're all super either you're
ashamed or you want to show your product
and I think that's the temptation and
every person I took to that showing me
their new company wants to show me the
product the truth is like resist this
sensation first try to ask me questions
because then it's too late like when
you've not read your blog that's the
moment you can ask so much because
people want to see what's new so they
will answer a few questions
and I I believe that you should spend a
lot of time listening to this
understanding and then saying you know
maybe 10% of your features and it
doesn't matter but not sure enduring
like if I do the full demo of front like
you'll be pretty bored now if I explain
to you
when I was in your seat using France I
think is one of the things that made us
successful as the company then and I'm
convinced and I'm obviously super biased
but I am convinced then maybe you'll be
more interested to hear so I'm gonna
transition a little bit before we go to
Q&A I don't know I have a feeling that
your fundraising experience was maybe
unusual I'm not representative maybe a
little bit too simple but maybe I'm
wrong about that were there any lessons
from fundraising that that you think are
useful besides grow really fast and have
a cool company because that helps right
so I mean yes it's unusual every every
time we've raised we've raised in a week
I think if I think about why though so I
think it's unusual and that's not what
you should expect now the thing that we
did well again I coming back to
discipline I've published all my series
seed Series A Series B deck there are
online so you can look at them and
you'll see that our metrics are pretty
good and it just like every single day
every single week in every single month
I care about hitting our targets and I
will do everything it takes for us to
eat our targets and that's what's shown
in these metrics and at the end of the
day even if of course people were
excited about the team we had the market
opportunity and whatever like if you ask
them why were they crazy about front
it's because of four metrics so yeah I
just so grow some good metric the thing
is you can't imagine like even if it
seems obvious the two things I've seen
that I know are wrong from founders one
is coming up with excuses so I'm you
know for example I'm helping you as a
company and you tell me I want a revenue
to grow and then you know the week after
we meet and I'm like what's your revenue
you're like I'm not focusing on that
because we had to redo our homepage
because the conversion blah blah blah
and I don't care about your conversion
like the only thing I care about is but
I think you've convinced yourself that
your website who is more important and
that's something that I see all the time
is as finding excuses for not growing
and I
understand how hard it is to admit that
you wanna grind and that's an issue and
you need to fix it but if you don't
admit it to yourself and your team then
you will not grow that's for sure
one alternative founder delusion yeah
and to is then bring discipline to force
you to face the reality and one way is
to send this weekly email to your team
monthly email to your investors like
it's I've invested in a few companies
since they I don't know in the past few
years and you can't imagine how I can
tell you after two or three emails so
two or three months which companies are
going to be successful and I don't know
if I'm the only one to have that opinion
or that insight
but I just feel like there are people
that will send in email and nothing for
four month and then email and then blah
blah or some people that will change the
format every single month in a some
people that are incredibly disciplined
about here are our KPIs and I will send
it to you every month and that's also
what I should my team and that's how we
have focused so important that's a great
lesson so last thing I want to talk
about was your co-founder recently got
sick and it caused the company to have
to you know do a whole bunch of things
and and and maybe change you to sort of
relook at your priorities and what was
important to you as a person as a CEO as
a friend as a co-founder and it's just a
human being in the company maybe you can
talk a little bit about about what that
experience has been like
sure so December 2016 so a year and a
half ago my co-founder was diagnosed
with a cancer and it was pretty bad and
now he's fine so oh good but it took 18
months and I think the thing that I
realized and that I would you know well
you're here and you're listening to how
to build a company every single day
you're working on your company it's so
important but you should remember that
like the most important thing is to be
happy and healthy
and as much as you care about this
company it's just a job and I can't it's
it's annoying to have to go through this
painful
to realize it but one thing that I do
now is anytime so there are many things
that I've changed personally and for the
company but at least anytime someone
join the company
I go through a presentation and I share
like what is France what I care about
and I will always tell them like first
and foremost be happy and healthy and in
front is not a place where you can be
and be happy and healthy you shouldn't
be here and you know Fran is important
but life is for more important than I
think them knowing that's that's how you
think is insanely important so just tell
the people you love that you love them
and spend time with your friends and go
on vacation and all these things are
equally important as price are more
important than pricing your product in
the right way and doing all these phone
calls etc that's just what I've been
asked to talk about the other thing is
one thing that changed my life is
meditation so and I'm also convinced
that it will change the life of probably
made under 95% of human beings so you I
felt like before I felt like I had a
choice between caring so much about my
company and so therefore being unhappy
because if you care so much even if your
company is doing okay there are so many
things to worry about
so I cared so much I was constantly
upset like I don't I'm worried this
customer is churning I'm worried this
person is not working out I'm already I
don't know how we'll hit our goals for
next for next month etc and or then
sometimes I tried to cure less but then
the company wasn't doing as well so I
was like either I care and I'm an IP or
I don't care and I'm an happy because
the company is not doing well so I'm
doomed
and I think meditation was really good
because I meditate 10 minutes every
morning I wake up have a shower meditate
for 10 minutes using headspace in this
and it's it's really something that
doesn't have immediate benefits so if
you're wedding like I don't feel better
after I've meditated it's just you have
to think about it as a muscle that
you're training and what it does is
really what it says which is headspace
so it's like I comes I could sell you if
you want how things are going at front
right now but just so many things need
to be figured out and the Tracy is I
feel great it's like I know that I have
a bunch of
to figure out and I know that either I'm
working on them are someone else is
working on them and so I care so much
but I have this headspace to not be
overwhelmed by everything bad that's
happening and that's by far has been the
thing that had the biggest impact in my
life and I think my co-founder being
sick is what led me to me being
overwhelmed to the point where I was not
sure that I could still run in front and
so I had to act and meditation was
another thing I did so try not to wait
until you have something that awful
happened in your your life or someone
you love or someone you're close to his
life we're going to spend more time on
the topic of how how to stay a human
being while you're doing is start up
tomorrow and Daniel gross comes in to
give a talk but with that let's go to
Q&A for a while yeah yeah so the
question is is around dealing with
safety and security when you're trying
to sell to enterprise customers and how
soon can you get it in their hands I
think things like that yes and so even
if you know we didn't start as an
enterprise cells we are dealing with
emails so security was a big deal so
what I would say is it's never enough
the thing is you have to find the
companies that are willing to take more
risks because you have no choice
like for us of course everyone wanted us
to be stuck to complain and stuff we're
still not set to complain today but what
we did we did a lot of things from you
know just a one pager that explained
everything about why our business is
secure to very early on Tesla started
using our product and they wanted to
make sure that they were using it for
product feedback and they were they
wanted to make sure that their
information was secure and so we did a
few penetration tests like that doesn't
cost a lot of money but you know
then if you can say again we had good
results and you can show the results to
other companies then at least it unlocks
some potential it's but the truth is you
also need to agree to not go after a few
industries or just not go after a few
customers because they always want more
but there are companies that will accept
to have their emails deal with a company
that's three months old nothing there's
nothing about anything that you know and
they were because there are a few thing
that you can show them okay you got the
same answer twice so hopefully that
helps yes how did you define why in the
end did you choose a subscription-based
model so I believe that people get more
benefit out of the product when they
have more users so that's the reason why
I also think that most of our most of
the competition so whether you're
looking at helpdesk solutions or email
products they charge per user per month
or per user per year so the combination
of everyone does it plus it seems in
line with the benefit that people get is
what led us to have a subscription model
yes what's the best way to notify your
users you're going to raise prices yeah
it's a good question so I think so I was
chatting with the president of Atlassian
about that and you gave me some good
advice which is the temptation is to say
we're going to raise our price but well
do they do that maybe you know year and
so you want to be nice and so you give a
lot of time the parameters you actually
make your customers angry twice because
by then they had forgotten and so then
BAM again it's almost as if you
increased twice so one trick I've used
so there isn't like just tell them and
and then do it sooner than later there
is no good way to do it one work trick
that I've used that I think is
successful is for us so we have monthly
subscription and you're ready
subscription and so you can tell them
that if they switch to a yearly plan
they will lock their price for one more
year which is win-win they pay less you
the money up front so at least that's
one way to show that you care about them
yes so randomly so how do you set the
target for the first salesperson you
hire so randomly the truth is I didn't
know because I was the only one doing
the job so there are a few ratio you can
hear us so for example they should bring
between 3x and 6x the the the amount of
money they are paid so then you have a
ranch because the truth if they bring
less than what they're paid probably not
good 10x like probably not good either
like you should hire more so once you
have that then building trust with your
first rep saying that's what I will
incor against I have no idea if it's the
right thing but let's reassess every
month and then let's be realistic about
what's feasible or not yes oh this is a
hard question so if users bounce how can
you find them yeah there are a few
technology that you can use like sherbet
is one of them but I mean for us we I
care more about the people that sign up
and end up never converting because they
should interest the truth is I think our
conversion rate on our website I don't
know is maybe 3% so there is so much and
we don't know about them so we don't do
much about them wiki funnels at the top
are difficult yes yeah how sorry how
early should you put pricing out there
and be transparent about it even even
while you're still in beta so it's a
good question one thing I did that I
think was a great idea was so
implementing stripe for us took some
time and so but I wanted to know if
people were willing to pay for the
product before we had stripe its
implemented
so in private beta when you signup to
France you would receive an automated
email from me saying what would you give
me to get access to your product or
product and so then I don't know so I
like Legos and that was my twitter feed
and some people would send me Legos
LEGO sets or like when our first
customer is a company called loomio they
do a lamp and so they said we'll give
you a lamp and so I guess I was just
very you know creative into trying to
understand what people were willing to
give and if it's not money doesn't
matter the truth is even giving an hour
of their time if you ask them you can
have access if you spend 30 minutes an
hour with me is a proof that they will
accept to give something in the back how
did you get those first 3,000 signups
for private beta so it was only content
marketing so I was doing an email
product and I was ready writing all
these blog posts about is email dead as
slack is saying or like all kinds of
think that I think people were curious
to hear about or what will you know look
like 20 years from now and content
marketing was or then I was at way C and
I was writing a something about what
it's like to be at YC a month in and
then another one what it's like to be
away see three months in and and just
people kept reading them and so content
marketing has been big for us I think
it's good in the early days I don't know
if it scales as much I don't think it
does but that's how we get our signups
yes so how do you adjust pricing in the
context of of feature demands or new
product demands from customers the
Tracy's new features are always a great
way to upsell and so usually with like I
was very happy to build a new feature
and put it in a new plan and say like
would you you can have a 30 day trial of
this feature but then would you be done
to double the price per user if you're
using that feature also something that
we
two years ago and I wrote a blog post
about this is we built a a back-end
system that enables us to each rate
super quickly on our pricing so if
tomorrow I want to change one of our
enterprise feature and put it in the
premium plan like I can easily do it and
I can just release the new pricing
doesn't gender anything for existing
users so that's a good way to just look
at your cohorts and see where does every
feature feed best we're gonna do one
more question right here so the question
is you quit your job because you wanted
to work an email but how did you figure
out what product to build so I think
email is a big crime to solve and so we
had to make sure that we had the right
go to market which was shared email
addresses as a way to enter this market
the reason is it was an easier product
to build people were willing to pay for
it and you could have a lightweight
deployment within an organization so
that's the entire company needs to use
France the reason I chose that is I had
a pain point when I was at this company
I remember that we had all these support
ad sales at addresses and people kept
asking me did you reply to this email
and I was like yes do you need to CCU
and every single you know so just
believe me that I replied to this email
and that's a pin point I had seen and so
I thought it was a great a good entry
awesome thank you material thank you so
much
you
you